police need your help finding this man
thank you so much for staying with us
here at 4 30. i'm christian kosovos i'm
kirsten joyce metro police say the man
allegedly exposed himself to a child in
the east valley on friday joe mohler is
live near charleston and lamb with what
police are doing to find him joe
people in the area are concerned this
happened just a few blocks away from a
school and even a park near charleston
and nellis if you live in this area
expect to see more police as they
continue their search for this man
around the corner jonathan arsey has
three small kids every single day
there's kids playing around kids is like
you know like walking he says he will be
extra cautious knowing police are
looking for a man trying to lure
children in this area after this you
know i was like i have to check like
double check make sure like everything
is all right police are looking for this
man they say friday he was trying to
lure a child and even expose himself in
the area of charleston west of nellis
the man was wearing a gray sweatshirt in
a white car possibly a toyota camry with
red and black seats or seat covers the
victim was recording the man while it
was all happening i would hope that they
could get all of them off
off the streets
terry pateo says these crimes are a
concern this is the second case like
this just this week 47 year old karen
lee sharon was arrested after police say
she tried to lure a child into her car
using candy in the southwest valley as
for this man police say they have leads
after multiple tips and are now
increasing patrols they say the more
people who see these images the better
hope they camp out on every street
looking for them
back out here live most of the police
that most of the people we talked to in
this area say they hope an arrest is
made soon if you know anything or might
recognize that suspect in those photos
police would like to hear from you or
you can call crime stoppers reporting
live in the east valley joe muller live
local now